can
multiculturalism exist without cultural
appropriation
i think this is a this is a great
framing and no
unless i mean unless you're seeking
parallel societies which is not really
multiculturalism it's
a kind of extreme form of live and let
live which probably doesn't work anyway
but of course there's borrowing and you
know this
have any cultural values been
appropriated inappropriately
uh yes of course and so you know is the
concept of cultural appropriation a
legitimate one
yes at base but um i
i feel about it i guess at this point a
bit like i feel about
uh the trans debate where like there's a
real thing
there's a real thing known as trans and
there are real people who really suffer
and there are real cultures who have had
their values or norms basically you know
minimized or you know stripped from them
as a result of some
other culture coming in and stealing or
betraying or whatever it is
but just as most of the people who are
currently in the debate
over in trans rights activist space
right now i don't think are good faith
um and are for the most part not doing
anything good for the very tiny tiny
number of people who are actually truly
trans
uh i don't think um that the vast number
of
accusations of cultural appropriation at
this point have anything to do
with actual harm to uh culture
it's it's power it's about power again
uh
and a misunderstanding of what history
is and what
and what people do i mean this this is
exactly how cultures evolve they evolve
sometimes by creating new things and
often by borrowing and adding
and you can see in fact that um a lot of
things
i think a lot of people who deploy you
know the idea cultural appropriation is
bad you're taking stuff you're not
paying for it right okay
i can sort of see the perspective on the
other hand this is what culture is
this is why we're not hardwired um and
so
you know at some level you should expect
this
but you know the point is if you start
to put these things together
you realize what this is is a set of
rules that cannot be abided by
right so i saw today coca-cola
uh a um internal
uh anti-racism briefing
escaped you know about whiteness right
yeah be less white or something like
that
well okay be less white and
don't culturally appropriate it is hard
to
disappear yourselves right like don't
don't exist well the basic point is look
you're going to be in violation of one
of these things or the other so
basically watch your step
because we can convict you on a moment's
notice we're watching and we're in
charge now
right used to it and likewise i would
say uh
you know i'm going to hate myself for
speaking like a child
now but um for the moment right the
the discussion around the n-word has
gotten completely preposterous and i'm
now
you know one of the wonderful things
about clubhouse is you can actually
listen in on discussions and you can
learn how people think about this but
at some level the word
is now super ubiquitous in
uh features in quadrants of black
culture
right i find no problem with that but to
to do that to infuse a you know hip-hop
culture or whatever
with this word so it's everywhere and
then
to hold a super high bar where somebody
who's simply singing along with a song
trips over it and is then convicted as
if they you know
used it as an epithet against someone is
preposterous
you know it's again a trap and so anyway
what we need is a an adult discussion
in which the proper level of nuance is
there
so that we can distinguish for example
between um
wielding an epithet and mentioning the
epithet
or you know using the epithet
as you are inhabiting a character a
racist character is it wrong to inhabit
a racist character and
you know use the syllables no of course
not right
we need racist characters in order to
understand the problem with racism right
so um so in any case you can't deploy
all of these things in isolation and
then combine them into some
web that can't be can't be navigated